Shannon sharp Oh Shannon sharp thank you
for your service right having to do a
show with that [__] jerk off all
these years I mean I don't know how he
does it I mean he's literally don't
anymore well he's literally a freaking
Adonis he's in a Hall of Famer and he
had to do a show with some guy that you
knew was the last dude picked in gym
class and he had to argue with this guy
no Skip Bayless looked at Shannon sharp
and basically said like you weren't that
good you were okay and like dude Shannon
sharp like took his glasses off and like
started like almost crying and freaking
out dude Skip Bayless man piece of work
that kid piece of work work